okay so as bill said I mean you're
talking about prof isn't profiling tools
for faster our code so thanks for would
be for coming I just want to say that so
one so here's a question that probably
comes up a lot if you work with are a
lot which is how do I make my our code
faster and that naturally leads to
another question which is why is my our
code slow and I my strategy for this
talk because I'm gonna walk you through
a couple examples and show you some of
the tools some of the tools that can
help you diagnose these problems and and
and speed up your code and hopefully
we'll also learn a bit about a few a few
particular things in our that might be
slow and surprisingly slow and ways to
speed it up okay so I'm just gonna start
with this example here let's say you've
got you've got a data frame that has
four hundred thousand rows and 150
columns and I'm just generating some
random data here with our normal and I
you know this this data is I picked it
because it's a good size for this
demonstration so it's there's nothing
special about this it's just it's just a
good size and good timing for this for
demonstrations here okay so one thing
you might do is well I'll write a
function that will normalize the column
so let's say I want to take each of
these 150 columns and make it so that
the mean of that column is 0 and so I
take oh sorry so that the yeah so the
mean of the column is 0 so I take the
original data for each column and then I
find the mean of that and then subtract
that mean from from each column so so
I've got this function norm calls and
what it does is it takes it takes the
mean of every column by using the apply
function like this and and then it
subtracts the mean that I've calculated
from each column and then returns the
resulting data frame so so this is
you know my first a first pass attempt
at normalizing normalizing these columns
okay
so then after I define this function
then I would say norm calls data on the
data that I've generated okay so let's
let's try that
so I've got my code here this is the
same code that you saw before first
don't generate the data it takes a few
seconds make more of a few seconds
unfortunately we don't have to do this
part once okay so it's done find my
function oops sorry
I type the next researcher there
accidentally sorry about that sort to
find my function oh I'm sorry
okay I just trying to print out the data
right now and that there's a lot of it
so it's very slow so let me just try to
stop this and restart my our session
okay all right so starting over let's
create the data okay
we'll define our function norm calls and
then and then we'll run the function and
this time we'll wrap it in invisible so
it doesn't try to print it out because
that that is very slow
that's what know if you saw that took a
few seconds to run that again do it
again so you can see it takes a few
seconds it's sitting there and then
returns to the console
okay so let's you know this is a it
takes a few seconds and if we want to
take a closer look at how the amount of
time that it takes sort of the first
pass thing that you might do is just run
system that time so you you have all the
same code and you wrap it in system time
and this tells you how long it takes to
run the code inside of it all right so
let's try that I have it right here and
the total time that took was 2.6 seconds
okay
so if you're trying to figure out what
you know parts of your code are slow or
how long things are taking this is the
first thing that you might do is just to
see see how long does it take but then
after that you know typically or you
left your own devices and you have to
you have to take a look at your code and
think about what sort of taking guesses
at what parts are slow and what parts
are not slow so and that that we can
require you know to get an accurate idea
of the parts that are expensive that
takes a lot of that can take a lot of
experience and sometimes even you know
your your what you think are is slow is
not that's not the right it's not
actually slow so in order to help out
figure out what parts are slow that so
you can speed them up we've got you can
use profiling tools so so R has a
built-in peripheral it's a sampling
profiler and what it does is it will
tell you what the our process is doing
over time so to use it it's really
simply just say our prof. then you run
your code and you say our profit all and
that stops the profiler so what happens
is is this is let's say this is time
along the x-axis here the our process
does a lot of computation it does a lot
of computation and then periodically
every I believe the default is 20
milliseconds over 20 milliseconds the
profiler stops our process and it and
it's it queries it and says what for
what function are you in right now and
our code is very simple so it'll be in
the new on calls function and then it
records that it saves that and then it
goes back and our process does all sorts
of computation here lots of computations
it's and then it gets stopped again by
the profiler and again it's in the norm
calls function so it writes that it
saves that again and it keeps going it
does this every 20 milliseconds until
until it's done so now obviously in this
case if if this is all that it recorded
this is not particularly helpful
information we know that we're in an
armed calls function all the way and all
in this entire time here well that
actually records more information than
that what it does is it records these
not just the sort of the outermost
function that's being called which was
no one calls it will also record public
functions in the cult what's called the
call stack so norm calls it calls apply
alright so this is our phone call to
norm calls here this is our function
definition and that it first called
apply and apply it turns out we'll call
a stunt matrix as that matrix a
dataframe
on list so this is the call stack and
then these are all our functions and
then at the top of the call stack
usually typically this this the
functions that are at the top of this
will call it to see code which the
profiler does not record and does not
give any give any insight into so that's
what happened what might happen at the
first at the first sample and maybe the
second sample the third sample there's
something different that happens like
norm calls calls apply so apply then
calls
mean which calls mean that defaults
and and so on and then eventually after
it does all the apply stuff then it will
call the - function because - you know
these operators in RR are all functions
so this this is the this is the
information that the sampling profiler
will record now the data that comes out
of the out of our prof the built in our
peripheral air is it's a little bit it
takes some practice and some expertise
to work with so so so we have a tool
oops oh yes actually I should go back to
here one important thing to remember is
that the if this is like the full
complexity of all the stuff that you're
that the computer is doing and all the
processing that it's doing this is what
the pro pro is going to tell you it's a
very low resolution of you of of what
the computer is doing but that's
actually but that's okay because you
know for this for this sort of thing
we're trying to you know we're trying to
find the large expensive things large
slow expensive things and speed them up
so we don't need to look at all the fine
detail typically in order to make
improvements we can see the large
features here like the continents and
the oceans and that's you know that's
that's sort of like those are the large
things that we need to look at for
speeding up our code okay so as I was
saying the the data that comes out of
the profiler and the two built-in tools
for our they do take some practice and
expertise to use so I've worked on this
package called prophase which makes it a
lot easier to interact with and
interpret the profiling information
that's that gets recorded so to use it
and say install the packages prophetess
and then why very cross this and then
you just take a code in the same code
and you wrap it in prophetess similar
similar to how we ran we use system that
time before but this time we just use
prophets okay so I'll show you what
happens if we do that this
this is our code here is there so let's
run it and I'm running this from within
our studio and when you're in our studio
it just pops up in in this panel right
here now if you're running it outside of
our scoot it will come up in a web
browser and it'll the interactions will
be exactly the same so okay so there's
two parts here that that show up in the
beginning there's the this is the code
here all right this is all whether we
ran and and then on the bottom there's a
flame graph so the code is pretty
self-explanatory well the code itself is
self-explanatory on the right there's
two little graphs for each line of code
that are useful so the first is that the
mobile the one that's most important is
the time so there is about seventeen
hundred milliseconds spent on this line
of code and about two hundred eighty
milliseconds spent on this line of code
and as you can see so in this line of
code there is about 2,000 milliseconds
and it actually turns out that this 2010
is the sum of these two lines of code so
it spent time in this line of code but
this line of code all called out to this
function and so it's ended up spending
time within these these other two lines
of code as well so that's the time
column the memory column shows how much
memory was allocated and D allocated
within each line of code so so in the
call to this norm calls function there
is two thousand megabytes of memory
allocated and nine hundred megabytes D
allocated I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a bit okay so that's
that's the that's the code and there's
this corresponding thing in the bottom
called a flame graph this is really
important so in the flame graph on the
x-axis is time so this is this is at the
beginning when we started and it goes
across over time as time was progressing
and this is where it ended so all the
time was all the time was
in the norm calls function and norm
calls called out to apply which we saw
before in that diagram that I showed you
and apply called as matrix which called
you know a bunch of public function as
what matrix ed data frame and unlist
after anyway after it finished during
after apply finishes doing as that
matrix and it calls a perm and that
calls this function what happens we
function we passed in which is the main
function and and then after apply
finished then it the minus function was
it called the minus function and this
whole thing took about about two seconds
so there is this well there's this GC
thingy which is a garbage collection
event this is this is when our allocates
a lot of memory and then and then it
when it decides it needs to free up some
other memory that it had previously
allocated it does a garbage collection
which stops everything all the
processing and it just spends time
clearing up memory and that's where
that's where the memory of deallocations
happen so if that - nine hundred three
megabytes that was the that's the
garbage collection event right there
okay so now if we talk about this code a
little talk about the code a little bit
and what's expensive here so the apply
function first it converts our data
frame to a matrix and then it calls a
perm on it which actually it's it's
essentially transposing the matrix and
so it does all of that work that takes
you know almost what 800 milliseconds
and that's just a transform the the the
the data into a form before it's can
start doing the actual work which is
taking the mean of each column all right
so that's that seems like that seems
kind of like kind of a waste so let's
you know let's if we think about some
other ways of getting the means of
columns that might be helpful so here's
one way that we can do it we can we can
just find some other ways of doing this
and then run prophetís on them so here's
four ways of doing it so the first was
to apply the mean function use
the apply function the next is to do
column means there is a built-in
function R for taking column means and
it seems like that should be pretty fast
right if there's a specialized function
for that and and there's two other ways
that we're gonna do here using L apply
and V apply so it turns out that this is
using the fact that data frames in are
implemented as lists so a data form is
actually a list of vectors each column
is one of those vectors so we can apply
L apply the mean fun over all of those
columns just by echoing like this and if
we apply does basically the same thing
except it enforces a return type which
might be useful but they're essentially
the same thing so if we run this code
let's go back to here we run it then
this will give us the ability to compare
these four different ways of getting
means so the first is a apply we knew
this was slow this time it's took about
seventeen hundred milliseconds the next
way that we we tried was call means
which is also it's much faster it's
about four times faster but it's not the
fastest way to do it which may be a
little bit surprising and then L apply
and V apply are both very fast so these
are both over each of these is over ten
times faster than our original method of
doing it
now again this profiler gives us some
useful information not just it tells us
not just that you know column means is
slower but it also gives us some insight
into why well oh yes and you can zoom in
here with the same graph you want a
closer look so the reason that it's
slower is because again Col means like
the apply function converts the data to
a matrix first and it actually you know
if you read the documentation for call
means it says that's what it's for but
is for matrix data but if you've given a
data frame it will course if your matrix
and that's that turns out to be an
expensive operation and
after that this little empty block here
this is where it's calling out to see
code to actually take the means and this
has been it's very fast but L applying
via plier are you know they don't have
that that matrix conversion step and so
there there overall much faster than
calling call means or apply okay so so
then we can go back and have our more
optimized version of the code in this
example I used V apply just because it's
a little bit more convenient to work
with the the data that comes out of it
but it's going to use L apply here as
well so we just make a copy of the data
take the means of each column and then
we would modify that data frame by
subtracting the means all right so let's
let's take a quick look at that okay so
so if this is our original thing we can
see you know we worked on the most
expensive the the slowest part of the
code first which was this line and now
that part is much faster this is the
corresponding card in our new code and
in this part this if now it's this line
that's lower so so there's actually some
room for improvement here but this is
already you know this is much much
faster than original code our original
originally it took let's see how long
was it about two seconds to run to run I
like to take a do the normalizing and
now it's taking us about 400
milliseconds so it's about five times
faster just by doing that one
optimization but again there's a room
for a little bit more improvement here
but I'm not gonna go into depth about
that okay so I want to show a second
example this is this is something that
actually this is a problem that came up
while I was working on per office and
haven't working on a process any data so
the the data that comes out of the that
that's recorded by the profiler looks
like this it's actually good CH for a
text file and this is a each line
text represents one sample one moment in
time and this is the call stack so it's
actually in the order so applies at the
bottom of a call stack and then as a
matrix as I made a matrix out data frame
and then unlist and the next sample is
like that and then you know sample
further down the line might only have
might be calling apply and then a perm
etc etc and there's about 750 lines of
this and we need this to be transformed
into a data frame that looks like this
where each each row in the data frame is
represents one of these samples and it
says it records the original row that it
came in which is essentially the time
which time step it was at and then the
column which was uh well it's in
reversed order here but this is this is
essentially the depth of in the call
stack and then the label so the way it
does this is it takes each line converts
it to a data frame and then into a small
data frame like this this you know this
four row data frame each line gets
turned into data frame and then it
sticks all those little data frames
together that's that's how it how it did
it originally and I'll just I'm just
gonna walk through this code real quick
and you can look at some of the things
that might seem like they're slow
alright so first we read in the read in
the the the text file it create a list
to store all this the puzzles those data
frames that we have little data frames
that could be created and then for each
line we process the line of text so
first we save the line in variable we
split up the line on spaces then we
create a data frame from that and then
we serve a data frame in the list and
then we just loop over it and keep doing
this for each line and then at the end
we combine all these data frames
together but you're calling do a call
and our bind okay so let's just run this
code real quick and let's see this is
okay so
forty milliseconds here and we can see
what's expensive so well let's actually
let's take a look first why don't we
take a look at some of the things that
seem like they should that they might be
expensive so so these are these are
typical things that typical things that
everyone in our community well but
people in our community are rules of
thumb that uh that are for things that
are slow so first you know this list
that I have here it's not pre-allocated
I'm using a for loop which is you know
people tend to say to avoid for loops
because they can be slow and then I'm
growing this list in the loop so because
I did not pre allocate the list every
time I add something to it it has to
allocate a whole new list so these are
things that seem like they should be
expensive
but if we take a look at the actual
profiling result here that's not
necessarily the case of Oh expensive so
again took about 40 milliseconds to do
all this and most of the time as we can
see was spent here creating data frame
there are some times spent splitting up
the string but more much more time spent
creating the data frames and at the end
putting through the data frames together
with the do call and our bind so so
that's that's interesting it's you know
actually storing the data and growing
this list in the loop that was actually
not very expensive it looks like that
took about 20 milliseconds total so it's
that's a negligible amount of time
compared to all their stuff that's
that's happening so so yeah so let's
just goes to show that sometimes it's
counterintuitive what the expensive
parts are creating data frames it turns
out is expensive in our so now I won't
go to detail about this but the way that
you can solve this or that I solve this
particular problem was instead of
creating a data frame for each iteration
of the loop is to put the data in a list
because that's the sense
what a dataframe is it just it's it's
essentially a list but dataframe
enforces a few a few things like each of
the vectors needs to be the same length
but if we're careful we can just use a
list instead and then I create a data
frame at the end by calling data dot
frame and then extracting out each of
these columns from the from the list of
lists that I have but again I won't go
into detail about this but I just want
to show you that now that we since we
know what the actual expensive parts are
here instead of spending time trying to
optimize the wrong thing by converting
it from a for loop to you know L apply
or something like that we could spend
time fixing the things that are actual
expensive which is the data frame
creation if I run this this faster
version of the code the whole thing took
takes 20 milliseconds okay as opposed to
400 and that's again that's that's we
can do this because we know we know with
that with the actual slow parts of the
code are that's that's what the
profiling tools give us information
about okay so those are my two examples
and and as you can see I've been using
profits with our studio and I I believe
this still requires a recent daily build
of our studio which you can find if you
just google for it our studio daily
build and our studio has some other nice
integration features which I want to
show you
so first is that there is a profiling
menu so I've been running all of this
stuff by you know wrapping these call
all my code in truff is but you don't
have to do it that way if you're using
our studio okay so what you can do is
you can say select your all of your code
that you want to run this is again this
is not wrapped in improv is this is like
if you're running your missus your you
know your code and your whatever our
file you're working on you can say
profile and then profile selected lines
few seconds and then it shows up here
like that so you don't have to you don't
have to modify your code and add profits
in there anywhere and once you have it
like this and you want to see if you
want to save it for later you can just
click on the Save button here well let's
just say call this temp so let's save it
as temp that our profit is okay so if I
close that and then I find it the file
here so let's attempt at our profits and
if I double click on it it'll open it up
up again here and also it turns out that
if you want to share this with people
there's a couple ways of doing it if you
can actually what you can do is this our
profits file is actually it is really
just an HTML file so if I if I rename it
to temp at HTML and double click on it
it opens it up in a web browser and and
I can interact with it the same way that
I was interacting with it before okay
because it lives just a web page so
that's so that's one way of sharing it
is that you can save it as an HTML file
and send it to somebody but you can also
there's a publish button here and if you
hit that you can publish it to our pubs
so and if you're not familiar with our
pubs it's just a free hosting service
that that our studio runs for for
documents
so I'll just publish it and I'll say
this of profetas example continue and
then it's online at this URL here so
then you can share this URL of people
and you can you know if you were trying
to if you want to show them how the
profiling of your code and and you know
what's fast and slow you can just send
them that URL so that's it's a nice
convenient way of doing it okay and one
other thing I want to show you is that
you can also do that's previously I
selected my code and I ran profile
profile selected lines another way that
you can do it is you can say profile
start profiling and then run your line
then run your code so well I guess I
only have to run this one here
so I started profiling then I ran that
line of code and it's still profiling
but then if I hit stop it stops and then
it pops up the information here but this
you when you do it this way you don't
get the source code showing up here so
that's it's it's not quite as nice that
way you don't you don't get to explore
your the code that you are running okay
oh yes and it's also as I mentioned
before you can use crosses without our
studio you know if you're using our and
in the terminal or our GUI or say are
from Emacs and you run prof is it will
open it up in a separate web browser
instead of instead of popping it up in
that in the our studio panel like I was
like I was working with there okay and
all right so that pretty much wraps
things up so some things to remember
hopefully from this you've learned how
the sampling profiler works and you've
got a feel for the prophets interface
and and also we've learned that
sometimes the performance bottlenecks
are counterintuitive and it's really
useful to have visualizations tools like
prophets in order to help you know
figure out what those bottlenecks are so
that you can fix them now if you go to
the the website for the package it's our
studio github is lash prophetess there's
a lot more information there there's a
lot of details that have glossed over in
this talk and if you're curious about
those careers about learning more about
it you can visit the website there okay
and I think I can take some questions
now so
first question is I run code of our
cluster is there a way to pull the
profile result to local I I don't think
that the profiler will give appropriate
information if you're running code on a
cluster or you know in a distributed
system so I I don't think unfortunately
the the profile records the information
that's necessary in order to give you
that the information that you want there
there's another one do you have to
define the functions in the prophetís
call or can you just call the function
that's that's a really good question so
in my examples I was defining the
function inside of the prophet's call
and what that gives you is that when you
do it that way you can view the code in
the code viewer if the code is if the
function is defined outside of the out
of the prophets call then you won't be
able to won't be able to see it in the
code viewer so that's what that gives
you now there are ways of loading if
you're say developing a package and you
want to load a package that you can see
all the source in the package there's
ways of doing it which are in the
website but um but generally speaking
it's it's best to run all the functions
in prophets that you can you can explore
them okay okay when I tried profess this
spring in our studio on a Linux machine
it did not work it only worked in
Windows our studio any progress
that is surprising to me so it should
work in our studio in Linux and if it
doesn't that that's a bug so now it's
possible that if you have an old version
of our studio it might not have come up
in our studio if that if that was the
issue
but prophase itself should should work
fine and across all our platforms okay
how will this work with shiny that is a
really good question I why don't I try
to find an example here okay
oops sorry it's our studio okay so I
have an example here of a shiny
application and I can I can run it
interactively too but on this website
there's an example about profiling a
shiny application I'll just run this
code since it's right there it's true
you know okay so I'm just using run
example to run one of the built in China
examples nope very shiny let's do it
okay so this is our tab sets example
slider on a few times
summary okay and then when I close the
shiny app profetas will know that it's
finishing to process the data it takes a
little time to process it okay now here
we go let me pop this out so it's a
little bit larger okay so this is this
is the shiny app there's a so the whole
thing was within this run example which
then called the run app and the
important things to look at are this
these outputs here is this so this is
blue or well I guess it's might be hard
to tell it's a it's actually a light
blue output dollar plot here and you
notice I I move that slider a bunch of
times and so every time it calls output
dollar every time it was that slider it
would rerender this plot and so this
gives you a view of like what's taking
time and I happen to have installed
shiny in the way that it displays all
the source code for shiny here so you
can actually look at admissible this
it's showing me all the internals for
shiny when I mouse over it which is
that's actually the reason that this is
a little
the inner interactions are a little bit
slow here so output dollar plot calls a
bunch of stuff you know and then it
called end up calling hist which was in
the example and a plot you know and so
on and so on
zoom in a little bit better look at this
but this gives you an idea of like
what's you know what takes time in the
shiny application now this is you'll
probably notice that well you'll notice
that the the call stack is significantly
deeper than in those simple examples
that I showed earlier but it's actually
far more complicated in that there's
this high to internal function calls
checkbox here and okay so let's I have
it split vertically instead of
horizontally so this is actually the
full complexity of what's happening in
in China and you can see there's just
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
function calls and so we you know
normally we try to hide all that
unnecessary information by using hide
function calls and so you see something
like this that's all it's a little bit
easier to interpret and again now this
is also in the if you go to the the
website for profits there's it has a
same example and and then in the website
there's all this all these things are
interactive as well so that because
because they are profits just just
generates webpages so it they can be
embedded into our marked on documents
which is how this is all generated so I
hope that that's helpful that give some
understanding of using it with shiny
okay let's see so here's a question I
don't see the profile of them in the top
command list it says I'm running that
the current version of our studio do I
need to use the daily update so a daily
update of our studio so I'm using our
studio about our studio this is version
$0.99 1281 these daily these daily
updates
there's
like sort of the release version of our
studio and then there's these daily
builds the the release versions will say
they're up to date but if you want all
the cutting-edge feature all about
cutting out features then you want to
use the daily builds so we can just you
know say our studio daily and and then
it will come up here our studio daily
builds I'm on a Mac so I'd say desktop
Mac and then they're just regular so I
would just download and install this
okay here's a question we discussed why
two thousand megabytes is allocated that
only nine hundred and three was D
allocated did the resulting new data
frame need one gigabyte of storage and
that was that was back with the bleep
was this example here so it what
happened was it allocated a lot of
memory while it was taking these means
it didn't deallocate at all because as
you can see during this processing there
was a garbage collection event that
happened partway through but at the end
there wasn't another garbage collection
event if there was another garbage
collection event here then I believe the
total memory used would have been it
would have D allocated to seal off that
it had allocated well not exactly
because it still needed to allocate some
memory for the means but that's that's
relatively small so and there's ways of
triggering the garbage collection you
can there's a function called GC which
will just trigger garbage collection so
if I had done that at the end it would
probably come out that way all right so
here's another question why is matrix
sizing a dataframe so computationally
expensive it's it's actually not
computationally expensive it's it just
takes a lot of memory it use it takes
requires a lot of memory allocation and
and moving stuff around memory that's
the expensive part in fact a lot of
times in our when when you have things
that are that take a lot of time but
they're surprisingly you know they're
things that are slow in our but are
surprisingly slow it's often because
they're moving a lot of memory around in
a way that's inefficient so that's stuff
that I did here you know using instead
of converting to a matrix and then
transposing
with a perm which is what apply does and
just using L apply directly that dad
saves time because it didn't it didn't
have to move stuff around in memory a
lot okay
another question here can I save the
profile file within our code so instead
of using the other art studio interface
and it is possible so if if you want to
be able to share this with people
without you know outside of our studio
or doing a programmatic way you can do
it so there's a frequently asked
questions section of profits and it is
how do I share there is okay so you just
run profetas save that save that in a
variable P and you can say HTML widgets
: : save widget and then and then set
the file name that's how you'd save it
without using without using the art
studio graphical interface okay
seriously this is a really good one in
the flame graph do blank the the blank
spaces correspond to C++ code C or C++
code being executed or time that you
aren't clicking on anything in the shiny
site so let's see so where is that last
okay so in this example so the blank
spaces so I think I well if it's these
blank spaces this means that there's or
at the very top above everything else
but that's time that is spent probably
in C code there's spaces between these
you know this the sort of empty space
between things this is just because in
these areas the call stack is not as
deep there weren't as many function
calls so that's why there's nothing in
between them now there are these cells
that are white there are cells in the
flame graph that are yellow and there's
ones that are white but yellow ones are
ones for which we have source refs and
that means that we can show that we can
show you the source code in the in the
code panel
so that was the code for this shiny
application and for shining itself
because as I mentioned I had loaded
shiny with with all the source the
source refs and so I can view them all I
can view all the shiny code in that cord
panel the white stuff these are weed for
these this is calling code that we don't
have source rust for so these are four
packages that we don't have what's
called source refs installed and that's
this is a these are probably in the base
or yeah that these functions were
probably in the base package and those
are not installed with source drafts by
default in our so we just don't have
them there's ways to do it so you can
install you can install it these
packages with sorceress but I haven't
done them okay okay how do you install
shiny is show internal functions great
okay we were just talking about this so
again this isn't a frequently asked
questions sections of the website let's
see how do we get code from an R package
just showing the cult code panel so
there's this question here and you need
to install the package with source
drafts so we basically typically well
you'd say install packages in the
package name type equal source and then
you could pass it this install option
with keep source and so any package that
you install that way the internals of
that package will CH will show in the
the code panel of prophets this coding
employer but nested functions worse and
memory usage I mean is it a good
practice to define a function inside of
another function that will call it you
know defining functions within for other
functions in R has a very very low
memory overhead and and also memory and
time overheads so that's actually it's
pretty much there's very little cost to
doing that and if you define functions
within functions and it can often help
like just to mentally sort out your code
so I you know if you have a place where
you're thinking about doing that I it's
it's probably a good idea but but
there's no there's probably no real
performance benefit or or penalty for
doing that okay here's another one well
preface works with code being run in
parallel say with a parallel package and
I believe the answer is no I haven't
really tried this out myself I think
somebody told me that it did not work
and that's because the built in our
profiler doesn't record information for
with parallel that that can be useful
yeah it doesn't record the information
that you need when you're profiling
using parallel